a vector is something that has both
magnitude and direction
magnitude
and
direction so let's think of an example
of what wouldn't and what would be a
vector so if someone tells you that
something is moving at five miles per
hour this information by itself is not a
vector quantity it's only it's only
specifying a magnitude it's not we don't
know what direction this thing is moving
five miles per hour in so this right
over here which is often referred to as
a speed this is a speed is not a vector
quantity just by itself this is
considered to be a scalar quantity if we
want it to be a vector we would also
have to specify the direction so for
example someone might say it's moving
five miles per hour east
let's say it's moving five miles per
hour due east so now this combined five
miles per hour due east this is a vector
quantity and now we wouldn't call it
speed anymore we would call it velocity
so velocity is
a vector we're specifying the magnitude
5 miles per hour and the direction east
but how could can we actually visualize
this so let's say we're operating in two
dimensions and what's neat about linear
algebra is obviously a lot of what
applies in two dimensions will extend to
three and then even four five six as
many dimensions as we want our brains
have trouble visualizing beyond three
but what's neat is we can mathematically
deal with beyond three using linear
algebra and we'll see that in future
videos but let's just go back to our
straight traditional two-dimensional
vector right over here
so one way we could represent it as an
arrow that is five units long we'll
assume that each of our units are our
unit here is miles per hour
and that's pointed to the right where
we'll say the right is east so for
example i could start an arrow right
over here and i could make its length
five the length of the arrow specifies
the magnitude so one
two
three four five
and then the direction that the arrow is
pointed in specifies its direction
so this right over here could
could represent visually this vector if
we say that the horizontal axis is say
east or the positive horizontal
direction is moving in the east this
would be west that would be north and
then that would be south now what's
interesting about vectors is that we
only care about the magnitude and the
direction we don't necessarily
care where we start where we place it
when we think about it visually like
this so for example this would be the
exact same vector or the equivalent
vector to this
this vector has the same length so it
has the same magnitude has a length of
five and its direction is also due east
so these two vectors are equivalent
now one thing that you might say is well
that's fair enough but how do we
represent it with a little bit more
mathematical notation so we don't have
to draw it every time and we can start
performing operations on it
well the typical way one if you want a
variable to represent a vector is
usually a lowercase letter if you have
if you're publishing a book you can bold
it but when you're doing it in your
notebook you would typically put a
little arrow on top of it and you
usually there's several ways that you
could do it you could literally say hey
five miles per hour east but that
doesn't feel like you can really operate
on that easily
the typical way is to specify if you're
in two dimensions to specify two numbers
that tell you how much is this vector
moving in each of these dimensions so
for example this one only moves in the
horizontal dimension and so we'll put
our horizontal dimension first so you
might call this vector five comma zero
it's moving five positive 5 in the
horizontal direction and it's not moving
at all in the vertical direction and the
notation might change you might also see
notation and actually in a linear
algebra context it's more typical to
write it as a column vector like this
five
zero this once again the first
coordinate represents how much we're
moving in the horizontal direction and
the second coordinate represents how
much are we moving how much are we
moving in the vertical direction
now this one isn't that interesting you
could have other vectors you could have
a vector that looks like this it's
moving let's say it's moving three in
the horizontal direction
and positive four so one 2 3 4 in the
vertical direction so let me see it
might look something like
it might look something like this
so this could be another vector right
over here maybe we call this vector
vector a and once again i want to
specify that it is a vector and you see
here that if you were to break it down
in its m in the in the horizontal
direction it is moving
it is moving three or it's it's it's
it's shifting three in the horizontal
direction and it's shifting four
positive four in the vertical direction
so and we get that by literally thinking
about how much how much we're moving up
and how much we're moving to the right
when we start at the at the end of the
arrow and go to the front of it so this
vector might be specified as
three
four
three four and you could use a
pythagorean theorem to figure out the
actual length of this vector and you'll
see because this is a three four five
triangle that this actually has a
magnitude of five and as we study more
and more linear algebra we can we're
going to start extending these to
multiple dimensions obviously we can
visualize up to three dimensions in four
dimensions it becomes more abstract and
that's why this type of notation is
useful because it's very hard to draw a
four or five or twenty dimensional arrow
like this